l'ordre du jeu vous rappelle l'examen
des conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture et de la
pêche dans la discussion générale
la parole est un monsieur gérard césar
rapporteur pour le sénat de la
commission mixte paritaire
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous aussi
arriver au terme d'un processus
législatives et rompre mon cher collègue
je crois qu'il ya une demande de rappel
au règlement formulée par monsieur
masson je vous en prie excusez moi mais
c'est la règle
j'avais prévenu tout à l'heure les
services madame la présidente
oui la semaine dernière en mon absence
mais notre collègue gérard longuet a
tenu des propos extrêmement de
désobligeant à mon égard et j'étais pas
là je ne savais pas mais ensuite
plusieurs sénateurs appartenant à des
groupes politiques différents
honte honte attiré mon attention sur ces
propos alors je les vis ils sont pour
que vous constatiez que dix ans on est
on atteint la limite
donc monsieur longuet a dit monsieur
masson est un collègue éphémère un
sénateur intermittents du spectacle dont
on se passe d'ailleurs très bien alors
je vais dire que d'abord je n'avais
absolument pas parler de monsieur
longuet c
une façon d'agir qui est à mon sens
intolérable et monsieur longuet ferait
mieux d'être plus prudents parce que
quand on s'appelle longue et on ferait
bien de mesurer ses paroles alors je
tiens à dire que si ça se reproduit
comme ça je suis prêt à dire ce que je
pense dans cet hémicycle de monsieur
longuet il a vraiment pas quand on
s'appelle longue et on a vraiment pas de
leçon à donner à personne
oui oui mon cher collègue
là il s'agit pas d'un rappel au
règlement mais d'une d'un règlement de
paix recette personnelle et d'ailleurs
et d'ailleurs je remarque à l'article 36
du règlement que la parole aurait pu
vous être accordées mais seulement en
fin de séance par un sénateur qui lui
demande la demande pour un fait
personnel envoyé on vous a donné la
parole maintenant soyez satisfait que
nous avons pris acte de votre
déclaration
excusez moi monsieur sy nateur chers
collègues de vous obliger à reprendre le
fil de votre discussion
je le fais bien volontiers madame la
présidente donc monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous voici arrivés au
terme d'un processus législatives
commencé avec le dépôt du projet de loi
d'orientation de l'agriculture de la
pêche
le 13 janvier dernier si la discussion
était rondement menée elle n'a pas été
bâclé pour autant plus d'une centaine
d'auditions plus de 50 heures de débat
en séance publique le sénat saisi en
premier ce texte a pu apporter sa pierre
à la construction de l'édifice
je vous remercie mon cher collègue
nos discussions sont intervenues un
moment particulier de notre histoire et
ricol après une période plutôt favorable
en 2007 et début 2008 nous avons connu
depuis la mi 2008 une crise d'une
ampleur exceptionnelle
après 20 % de baisse en 2008 le revenu
des agriculteurs a chuté de 30% en 2009
le secteur laitier est emblématique à
cet égard et symbolise bien le
bouleversement des repères du monde
agricole face à situation cofaq t-il
faire entre stratégie du dos rond et
celle de l'action vous avez choisi mais
c'est le ministre l'agriculture
la deuxième solution les perspectives de
réforme de la pac après 2013 imposé ne
pas rester les bras croisés
je constate et au demeurant le texte de
la loi de mutation de l'agriculture et
de la pêche qui vise à apporter des
solutions à moyen terme anticipe sur les
propositions européennes
ainsi le groupe de haut niveau sur le
lait ghn qui a rendu son rapport le 15
juin préconise la mise en place de
contrats écrits portant sur les prix les
volumes et délais de livraison entre
producteurs de lait transformateurs afin
de donner de la visibilité et lisibilité
aux acteurs après la fin des quotas
laitiers en 2015
cette recommandation nous la mettons
déjà en oeuvre avec l'article 3 de la
loi
mais avant de parler du fond du texte
qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui je
voudrais vous remercier monsieur le
ministre je crois pouvoir le faire au
nom de tous dans cet hémicycle pour
votre grande disponibilité votre grande
écoute
notre souci constant d'apporter des
réponses quant aux tirs et concrètes à
nos interrogations
merci monsieur le ministre votre
ouverture d'esprit et votre grande
compétence ont contribué à la qualité de
nos débats
je souligne également la très bonne
tenue une discussion en commission
soient bien son nom au président
jean-paul emorine en séance publique
car derrière nos divergences de
philosophie comme il souligné madame
hervio lors de la commission mixte
paritaire
nous avons su nous écouter et surtout
échanger nos arguments en fait je salue
le travail de nos collègues députés et
le rapporteur michel raison
ainsi que de rapporteur pour avis et
christian patria et charleroi l'occasion
d'évoquer également le travail de louis
guay dans rapporteur ce nouveau les
pêche et aquaculture l'assam et la cena
n'a pas en effet premier en cause des
principaux apports du sénat ce texte
elle n'a pas bouleversé les grands
équilibres kusai ont su trouver sur
l'assurance en particulier sur la
contractualisation sur les
interprofessions ou encore sur
l'étiquetage d'origine
ce respect mutuel entre les deux
assemblées a permis assez facilement de
se mettre d'accord sur un texte en cmp
depuis son dépôt le texte est passé de
24 articles à 66 après lecture au sénat
et 26 et 96 article pardon maintenant en
sortir
commission mixte paritaire le parlement
n'ont donc pas été une chambre
d'enregistrement bien le contraire la
commission mixte paritaire adopté plus
d'une centaine d'amendements
beaucoup sont rédactionnelle ou porté
sur les mesures de coordination et de
précision mais quelques uns sont plus
substantiel sur le tir premier la scène
nationale a confirmé l'orientation de la
politique alimentation vers le site
leurs cours et le développement de
l'information sur l'origine des produits
la cmp a confirmé les ajouts de la scène
nationale définition d'un statut
législatives pour le programme national
nutrition santé mise en place d'une base
juridique nouvelles pour le système de
cotation pour les verts la cmp a
également précisé
certaines dispositions introduites
rassembler comme l'encadrement à
l'article 1er terres à des possibilités
de léguer un produit et à la truffe ou
truffé ou encore la sanction lartigue
premier terme et des détournements de
notoriété des produits bénéficiant d'une
appellation d'origine ou encore
l'extension l'outre-mer de la mention
valorisante produits de pays
si le titre de véritable coeur du texte
la version sortie l'assemblée est
largement la même que celle votée au
sénat
l article 3 sur la contractualisation le
principe de priorité de l'accord
interprofessionnel pour définir un
contrat type a été maintenu à l'article
4 les obstacles et me prennent à la
pratique des prix après vente sont
restés dans le texte l'assemblée ayant
simplement préciser les conditions dans
lesquelles peuvent se dérouler des
ventes la commission effectué par
mandataire à l'article 5
l'interdiction totale des remises rabais
et ristournes 3r dans le secteur des
fruits et légumes frais kusai ont adopté
a été confirmée les députés ont demandé
un rapport annuel sur les accords de
modération de marge situé l'article 5
bis
le texte de la cmp conforte les
habitants du sénat concernant
l'observatoire des prix et les marges
celui-ci aura un président les
opérateurs qui refuseraient pour nos
enquêtes statistiques pourront être
sanctionnés non seulement par une amende
mais également en dévoilant leur
identité au grand public
sur les interprofessions de longues
discussions ont été menées mais la
majorité tant au sénat qu'à l'assemblée
nationale considère qu'il appartient à
leur qualité d'organisme doit priver de
déterminer librement leur radiation
interne qui devra bien sûr
nécessairement évoluer si l'argument de
producteurs le texte proposé encourage
la constitution l'association donation
de producteurs à l'article 8
les regroupements est indispensable pour
faire changer les rapports de force
le dispositif d'assurance prévue
l'article 9 a été préservé la commission
mixte paritaire est également revenu à
la rédaction du sénat concernant les
engagements du gouvernement en matière
de réassurance publique à l'article 10
nous appartenons particulièrement ces
avancées sur la question de l'assurance
auquel nous avons beaucoup travaillé en
particulier avec notre collègue daniel
soulage et surtout avec le président
jean paul emorine
notons aussi pour le secteur viticole
que l'assemblée adopté un article donne
à une base juridique à la distillation
de crise obligatoire et que la cmp a
rétabli l'article du sénat permettant
une diminuation de vente unifiée des
vins sous appellation d'origine
contrôlée aoc
enfin la commission mixte adopté la
rédaction du compromis de l'assemblée
nationale concernant les installations
classées d'un secteur d'élevage
les recourants d'élevage restant soumis
au régime des icpe installations
classées pour la protection de
l'environnement mais dans un cadre qui
n'empêchera plus sobrement alors que de
fait la situation est actuellement gelé
par ailleurs l'examen des demandes
d'autorisation et les délais de recours
ont été raccourcis pour mettre fin cette
situation de blocage
l'assemblée nationale a regroupé les
dispositions fiscales adopté au sénat
le titre ii bis a intitulé améliorer la
compétitivité des stations ricol c'est
bien là notre préoccupation
lorsque nous avons voté ces articles et
sur ce titre la commission mixte
paritaire a confirmé la suppression de
l'article 11 bis adopté au sénat qui
visait à permettre aux viticulteurs de
remettre en cause le forfait à l'école
lorsque ceux-ci ne comprenait pas la
catégorie pour laquelle
le vin est effectivement vendus la cmp a
supprimé la des liens gestion partielle
entre la dpa déduction pour aléas et
l'assurance introduit par michel raison
considérant qu'ils agissent et une
orientation contradictoire avec celle du
titre 2 la commission mixte paritaire a
confirmé la possibilité de constituer en
gaec entre époux ainsi que les autres
apports du sénat et de l'assemblée
nationale notamment en matière de
lissage des revenus sur l'installation
la cmp a confirmé dans ses grandes
lignes le texte issu du sénat
elle a fait du même concernant la taxe
sur les plus values à l'occasion de
l'inauguration des terrains agricoles
article 13 qui a été affecté à
l'installation en matière de foncier
l'assemblée nationale avait voulu
souhaité étendre la compétence la
commission départementale la
consommation des espaces agricoles en
prévoyant qu'elle donne un avis sur
l'élaboration et la révision du scot
si ceux ci ont pour conséquence une
réduction des espaces agricoles
la commission mixte paritaire entériner
cette extension ministre la question de
la forêt a été plus conflictuel et
députés qu'ils avaient pourtant voté en
séance se sont imposés 1 cents et à
l'utilisation du compte épargne
d'assurance pour la forêt pour des
travaux d'investissement apport majeur
du sénat allouani médiation de
l'agriculture et la forêt et leur pêche
le compte d'épargné d'assurance
forestière et sera donc limitée travaux
liés aux sinistres forestier ce qui
n'est pas rien le dispositif comporte
également de louis sommes pas une aide
au paiement de la prime d'assurance
le texte de la commission mixte
paritaire prévoit par ailleurs une
orientation prioritaire des crédits
issus des cinquièmes forestier en faveur
des actions des chambres d'agriculture
de concernant la forêt la cmp s'est
également accorder ce droit de
préférence des voisins en cas de cession
de parcelles forestières
en fait la commission miss a confirmé
les dispositions du titre iii bis
regroupant différentes mesures de
simplification du droit aux agriculteurs
et celle du titre 5 relative à
l'agriculteur
et l'agriculture et la pêche
ultramarines au titre simplification la
commission mixte paritaire entériné la
décision de confier aux chambres et
culture l'émission d'informations sur
l'installation en conclusion monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues -
présidente
je crois que malgré des délais très
courts le sénat comme la scène nationale
ont su faire évoluer texte de loi
d'orientation de l'agriculture et de la
pêche dans un sens très positif ce texte
nous fournit les outils pour nous
projeter dans l'avenir mais aussi et
surtout pour préparer notre futur enjeux
de l'après 2013
je propose donc d'adopter les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire
merci chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur charles robert
rapporteur pour le sénat la commission
mixte paritaire à mme la présidente
ce ministre mes chers collègues les
réformes qui font peu de bruit sont
souvent les meilleurs et les plus
profondes
le volet pêche et aquaculture n'était
peut-être pas le plus visible de la map
et mais il est loin d'être insignifiant
il créé les outils propice son
développement tant attendu de
l'aquaculture marine modernise la
gestion des quotas à travers les
organisations de producteurs et
ressentent les comités des pêches dans
le cadre d'un réseau plus resserrée qui
correspond mieux à la réalité de la
peine aujourd'hui je me joins à gérard
césar pour vous féliciter monsieur le
ministre pour votre disponibilité et
seigle et saluer votre grande compétence
je salue également l'engagement de notre
président de la commission de l'économie
du développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire
naturellement je remercie le rapporteur
de l'assemblée nationale louis guédon
pour le travail effectué sur ce volet
pêche et aquaculture qui a eu le mérite
de préciser certaines dispositions
que nous avions introduites sur le volet
pêche et aquaculture la commission mixte
paritaire a permis assez facilement de
sera de rapprocher les points de vue des
deux assemblées
car nos approches convergeaient nous
sommes tous d'accord en effet pour
renforcer les liens entre pêcheurs et
scientifiques
le texte initial de leur type le 18 le
faisais à travers les que le comité de
liaison scientifique et technique des
pêches maritimes et de l'aquaculture sa
composition a été élargie au sénat
l'assemblée nationale a conservé ses
dispositions mais a souhaité donner un
statut législatif au conseil supérieur
d'orientation des politiques
halieutiques aquacole et à lyon
alimentaire en intégrant en son sein des
parlementaires
la cmp a prévu la présence de
parlementaires au sein du seul comité
liaison afin de ne pas multiplier les
organismes extraparlementaires la
commission mixte paritaire a par
ailleurs conservé l'idée du sénat
d'encourager l'analyse conjointe de
l'état de la ressource par les pêcheurs
et les scientifiques à travers des
expéditions sur les mêmes navires et en
même temps le sénat avait créé des
conférences régionales sur l'utilisation
de la mer et le littoral
la commission mixte paritaire a adopté
la rédaction de l'assemblée nationale
qui a prévu que la concertation
s'effectuerait à l'échelle de la façade
maritime est celle retenue au demeurant
pour les schémas de façade par le ghana
le grenelle de l'environnement
concernant l'aquaculture des principales
avancées du texte du sénat consistant
notamment à mettre sur le même plan le
schéma régional de développement de
l'aquaculture et les autres schémas ont
été préservés l'objectif commun est bien
permettre enfin à cette activité de
décoller pour améliorer notre
autosuffisance en matière de produits de
la mer
alors que plus de 80% fois voir ce
pourcentage à l'esprit de nos besoins
sont actuellement couverts par des
importations sur la répartition des
quotas et le pouvoir du comité des
pêches en matière de gestion de la
ressource
le sénat avait établi les compétences
des comités des pêches pour organiser
l'accès à la coquille saint jacques
le sénat avait aussi maintenu le régime
des délibérations approuvées du comité
national des pêches
ces dispositions n'ont pas été modifiées
par l'assemblée nationale concernant
l'organisation professionnelle des
pêches maritimes et de l'aquaculture la
suppression des comités locaux a été
confirmée mais des antennes locales
pourront substituer subsister pardon
comme échelon déconcentrés des comités
départementaux ou des comités régionaux
nous sommes dans les faits attaché un
lien de proximité dans chaque port entre
les pêcheurs et les organisations qui
les représentent
cependant il n'est pas raisonnable
financièrement ni pertinent
techniquement de conserver partout un
comité local lourd avec l'élection de
ses membres mais prélèvement une
contribution professionnelle obligatoire
la profession n'a pas les moyens
d'entretenir un réseau aussi dense et
l'échelon de proximité doit se consacrer
aux missions proximité ce ne peut être
aller son du port que l'on réfléchisse
de la stratégie en matière de gestion de
la ressource
toujours à l'article 21 l'assemblée
nationale a précisé utilement le statut
des membres des comités des pêches
je salue enfin les articles ajoutés par
l'assemblée nationale sur lesquelles la
commission mixte paritaire n'est pas
revenu sur le fond l'article 18 bis qui
prévoit d'étudier un plan de lutte
contre les pollutions marines engendrés
par le chlordécone l'article 19 bis qui
précise les conditions de premières
ventes des produits de la mer
l'article 23 bis à qui précise la
répartition des ressources du produit de
la taxe sur les éoliennes en mer
ne volez pêche et aquaculture et donc
beaucoup plus consistant que certains
ont pu le penser en premier lieu bien
entendu n'épuise pas le sujet la future
réforme de la politique commune de la
pêche au niveau européen aura une
importance capitale pour l'avenir de ce
secteur ont d'ailleurs adopté une
résolution dans ce sens au niveau de
notre commission
notre pays a une longue tradition pêche
et de cultures marines ostréicole et
mytilicole il est nécessaire de
préserver notre type de pêche et même de
le développer
là où c'est possible je pense en
l'occurrence aux espaces maritimes
ultramarins qui reste largement
sous-exploité enfin je me réjouis que
nous donnions une impulsion
significative à notre aquaculture car la
filière des produits de la mer a besoin
que toutes ces branches se structure
afin que l'ensemble de la filière soit
forte
une attention particulière devra aussi
est cependant est également portée à
l'avenir de l'aquaculture d'eau douce je
vous propose donc d'adopter les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur bruno le maire
ministre de l'alimentation de
l'agriculture et de la pêche
madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission d'économie
messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je suis très heureux comme charles revêt
vient de l'indiquer lui-même de pouvoir
clore ces débats sur la loi de
modernisation à la culture de la pêche
je voudrais commencer mes propos en vous
remerciant de la qualité des échanges
que nous avons eus aussi bien en
commission de l'économie que en séance
publique ce débat correspond
parfaitement à l'idée que je me fais
d'une démocratie constructive ce texte
de modernisation de la culture de la
pêche c'est votre production également
c'est le fruit des échanges que nous
avons eus au service de la modernisation
de l'agriculture et de la pêche
française pourrait remercier tout
particulièrement les rapporteurs charles
revêt pour la pêche gérard césar pour
tous les volets agricole pour le travail
de concertation préalable qu'ils ont
fait le travail décent ge d'audition je
sais que ce sont les centaines d'heures
de travail qui ont été passées à écouter
les professionnels les responsables
agricoles les représentants syndicaux
pour essayer de comprendre ce qui était
attendu par l'agriculture et par la
pêche française et grâce à eux
en tout cas je l'espère nous avons
répondu à ses attentes
je remercie aussi tout particulièrement
le président de la commission de
l'économie jean paul emorine qui a
veillé à ce que ce texte arrive à bon
port dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
il l'a fait à la fois avec toute la
compétence et toute l'autorité que
chacun lui reconnaît
ce texte marque a à mon sens un tournant
majeur dans l'agriculture et dans la
pêche française
il doit permettre au sortir de la crise
terrible qu'ont connu les agriculteurs
et les pêcheurs en 2009
de redonner un élan à ce qui reste la
première agriculture en europe
ce texte fixe pour la première fois une
direction politique à l'agriculture et à
la pêche française
cette direction c'est celle de la
sécurité alimentaire de tous les
français
l'alimentation revient au coeur des
objectifs politiques de notre
agriculture et de notre pêche
je pense qu'il était temps de l'écrire
et de prendre les dispositions
nécessaires pour le faire c'est que ce
que vous avez fait dans cette loi
ce texte marque un tournant majeur parce
que il met fin à un certain nombre
d'exceptions françaises qui étaient
autant de faiblesses de notre modèle
pour renforcer ce qui fait les
véritables valeurs de notre modèle de
développement agricole et de la pêche
jusqu'à présent les contrats étaient
l'exception dans les filières agricoles
françaises et il laissait par conséquent
les agriculteurs et les pêcheurs seul
face aux variations de prix et à la
volatilité croissante des prix dans les
cultures et de la pêche
désormais avec la loi de modernisation
de l'agriculture et de la pêche
les contrats seront la règle les
contrats seront obligatoires pour les
industriels vis-à-vis de leurs
producteurs ils permettront de sécuriser
le prix la durée le volume de la
production agricole en france ils
permettront donc d'atteindre ce que nous
souhaitons tous un revenu stable et un
revenu décent pour tous les agriculteurs
en france les outils dont dispose l
agriculture française contre des risques
croissants risques sanitaires risques
environnementaux risques économiques
étaient tous lacunaire et la plupart des
filières agricoles ne pouvait pas
disposer de moyens pour se prémunir
contre le risque désormais grâce à la
loi de modernisation de l'agriculture de
la pêche
nous avons opéré une refonte totale des
outils de protection de l'agriculteur et
des pêcheurs face aux risques désormais
nous avons prévu que pour chaque risque
qu'il soit sanitaire qui choix
environnemental qui choix économiques
les agriculteurs en france disposeront
enfin des réponses dont ils ont besoin
des garanties qui sont nécessaires des
protections qui leur permettront de
parer aux risques
la création du fonds national de
garantie contre les risques agricoles
qui couvrent pour la première fois les
dispositifs assuranciels les fonds de
prévention les dispositifs de soutien de
l'état contre les calamités agricoles
permettent de répondre à tous les
risques auxquels les agriculteurs sont
confrontés
je sais que le président jean paul
emorine il était particulièrement
attaché et je tiens à le remercier car
je crois que c'est un pas important qui
a été fait pour la sécurisation du
revenu des agriculteurs
je veux dire un mot en réponse à gérard
césar sur la question de l'épargné forêt
je sais que la volonté des sénateurs
dans leur grande générosité était
d'ouvrir ce compte épargne forêt à
l'investissement en forêt le
gouvernement dans sa grande rigueur a
préféré s'en tenir à un compte qui ne
touche que les pagnes je crois que
l'essentiel et nous pouvons tous en
convenir
ici c'est qu' aucune filière agricole y
compris la forêt ne sera laissée sans
dispositif assurantiel pertinent pour
faire face aux risques
voyons ce qu'il ya de positif là-dedans
et je sais que c'est exactement ce qu'a
fait gérard césar en cmp et voyons que
pour la première fois de l'histoire
agricole française
il n'y aura plus une seule filière sans
dispositif de protection face aux
risques
nous avions un défaut de transparence
sur les circuits commerciaux
nous avons à votre initiative
considérablement renforcer
l'observatoire des prix et des marges et
nous mettrons j'en prends l'engagement à
la tête de l'observatoire des prix et
des marges
une personnalité qui aura toute la
compétence et toute autorité nécessaire
pour mettre fin à un certain nombre
d'abus nous ne pouvons pas continuer à
accepter qu'un producteurs produisent un
kilo de fruits ou de légumes à 60
centimes d'euros de coûts de revient qui
le retrouve ensuite vendu à perte à 40
centimes d'euros et qu'il le retrouve
enfin dans le circuit de
commercialisation grande distribution ou
ailleurs un euro 60 1 euros 70 voire 2
euros sans que cela lui permette de
couvrir son propre coût de production ce
n'est pas possible nous avions un
éclatement de la profession agricole
avec l'interprofession qui manqué
d'autorité et des organisations
professionnelles qui étaient divisés
vous avez prévu dans ce texte de loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture et la
pêche
un renforcement de l'organisation de
producteurs un renforcement des
interprofessions là plus qu'ailleurs
dans le domaine agricole plus
qu'ailleurs
l'union fait la force cette union c'est
vous qui l'avez mis en place à travers
les dispositifs de cette loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture
et c'est vrai en particulier pour la
pêche cher charles revêt puisque cette
fois préfigure la mise en place d'une
véritable interprofession de la pêche
pour la première fois en france nous
aurons je l'espère d'ici la fin d'année
2010 une interprofession de la pêche qui
permettra de défendre au mieux les
intérêts des pêcheurs en france vous le
voyez toute l'orientation de cette loi
c'est de permettre à nos agriculteurs à
nos pêcheurs de mieux défendre leurs
intérêts de mieux défendre la qualité de
leur production de mieux défendre tout
simplement leur travail face à une
concurrence accrue en europe et ailleurs
cette loi renforce la compétitivité de
l'agriculture française et lui permet de
préserver le modèle auquel nous sommes
tous attachés de présence sur l'ensemble
du territoire des agriculteurs et des
pêcheurs
ce texte répond également à des
préoccupations très concrètes
mais ces préoccupations concrètes
auxquelles vous avez su répondre c'est
vous mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
qui avaient mis le doigt dessus et qui
avait su il y apporter les réponses
pertinentes
je pense à des dispositions qui ont peut
être est ce un peu au grand public mais
certainement pas aux professionnels
agricoles qui les attendaient depuis
longtemps je pense à la création du gaec
entre époux est une manière de
reconnaître très concrètement la valeur
du travail des conjoints je pense à la
suppression des remises rabais et
ristournes qui est votre initiative le
gouvernement souhaitait aller moins loin
c'est vous qui avez proposé c'est vous
qui avait demandé la suppression totale
des remises rabais et ristournes pour
mieux équilibrer les relations commerce
je pense à l'affectation de la taxe sur
la spéculation sur les terres agricoles
que nous avons attribué à l'installation
des jeunes agriculteurs si vous mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs nous n'avions
pas demandé pouces et l'affectation de
cette taxe pour les jeunes agriculteurs
ce ne serait pas eux qui devraient
bénéficier c'est votre résultat les
jeunes agriculteurs vous doivent
beaucoup
je pense également à la réassurance
publique
voilà des décennies que les
gouvernements essaye successivement de
mettre en place une réassurance publique
pour arriver à créer un certain nombre
d'outils assurantiel qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui les éleveurs en france je le
dis devant jean paul emorine qui a été
le maître d'oeuvre de cette réassurance
publique ne dispose d'aucun outils
assurantiels à ce jour et il n'en
disposent pas parce que faute de
réassurance publique
les assureurs privés ne veulent pas
proposé d'instruments assurantielle
pertinents c'est parce que vous avez
exigé la réassurance publique insisté
auprès de bercy auprès de matignon en
interministériel pour obtenir cette
réassurance publique qu'elle est
désormais mise en place et qu'elle
permettra la création d' outils
assurantiels y compris pour l'élevage y
compris pour les fourrages permettant
ainsi d'avoir une assurance dans
l'ensemble des filières agricoles
c'est pour vous un véritable succès et
s'est posé agriculteurs une avancée
majeure
je pense également mais je manque de
temps malheureusement pour évoquer tous
les débats que nous avons eus je pense
également aux débats très concret et
très passionnant que nous avons eues sur
la reconnaissance de la truffe sur la
clairette de die sur les viande aubrac
et de s'inverse en lozère jacques blanc
car vraiment qu'à tous mes devoirs si
vous n'avez pas cité la lozère en
présence de jacques blanc tout cela tout
cela confiant tout cela confirme
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs que
vous restez les meilleurs spécialistes
du monde agricole
gt gt lundi au conseil des ministres de
l'agriculture à bruxelles et cette
nouvelle réunion du conseil des
ministres de l'agriculture à bruxelles
m'a confirmé dans mon idée que ce texte
de loi n'est pas un achèvement
mais qu'il n'est qu'un début pour
redonner un vrai élan à l'agriculture
française
les positions françaises sur la
régulation européenne des marchés
agricoles
était il y a moins d'un an totalement
isolés en europe et suscité les
réactions négatives de l'ensemble de nos
partenaires européens et de la
commission européenne
après un an de travail après un an de
discussions et de pédagogie
après un an de conviction les positions
français sur la régulation européenne
des marchés agricoles sont le point
d'équilibré des discussions en europe
sur l'agriculture le rapport laguiole
qui était adoptée par le parlement
auront 1 reprend mot pour mot les
propositions formulées par la france et
par l'allemagne en juillet et en août
dernier sur la régulation des marchés
agricoles
le rapport du groupe de haut niveau qui
a été remis lundi au conseil des
ministres à la culture reprend mot pour
mot les propositions françaises formulée
en juillet et août dernier et reprend
nombre de dispositions que vous avez
voté dans le cadre de la loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture et de la
pêche
je pense à la mise en place des contrats
entre industriels et producteurs qui est
recommandé par la commission européenne
et par les états membres comme la
solution pour la stabilisation du revenu
des producteurs
je pense à la transparence sur les
volumes et sur les circuits commerciaux
qui corresponde mot pour mot à ce que
vous avez choisi dans le cadre de la loi
de modernisation de l'agriculture et de
la pêche
je pense au renforcement des
organisations de producteurs je pense au
renforcement de l'interprofession je
pense à la modification de droit de la
concurrence pour permettre aux
producteurs de mieux négocier leurs prix
avec les industriels
tout cela vous l'avez vous lu avec un
temps d'avancé sur les autres pays
européens dans le cadre de la loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture et de la
pêche c'est un vrai succès pour
l'ensemble des représentants
du peuple français ce texte de loi une
fois encore n'est pas un achèvement
il est un début il devra se poursuivre
par la mise en place de plans de
développement des filières toutes les
filières ont besoin de soutien pour se
moderniser pour innover pour investir
pour se restructurer pour être toujours
plus compétitive de façon à maintenir
l'activité agricole sur l'ensemble du
territoire
je présenterai ses plans de
développement à partir du mois de
septembre prochain
concernant les filières du lait les
filières de l'élevage puis les filière
des fruits et légumes puis les grandes
cultures de façon à accompagner chacune
de ces filières dans les développements
nécessaires
je pense en deuxième lieu au choix sur
la politique agricole commune qui vont
se dessiner d'ici la fin de l'année 2010
nous avons je viens de le dire gagner en
persuasion nous avons fait de nos
positions le point d'équilibré des
discussions européennes
il faut maintenant marquer l'essai
poursuivre nos efforts nous le ferons
notamment en présentant une position
commune franco allemande au mois de
septembre prochain
l'agriculture qui divise depuis vingt
ans la france et l'allemagne au plus
haut niveau
l'agriculture qui a provoqué des crises
politiques majeures entre la france et
l'allemagne depuis 20 ans sera désormais
un point d'entente entre nos deux pays
et je pense enfreint aux négociations
internationales sur lesquels il n'est
pas question de baisser la garde
nous ne pouvons pas accepter que
l'agriculture soit la variable
d'ajustement systématique des
discussions internationales que ce soit
avec le mercosur ou dans le cadre de l'
omc
je voudrais terminer mon intervention et
conclure pour vous redire tout le
plaisir et tout l'honneur que cela a été
pour moi de défendre ce texte devant
vous j'ai beaucoup appris de cette
discussion et je tiens à vous en
remercier mon dernier mot sera
évidemment pour les agriculteurs et pour
les pêcheurs de france pour leur dire
toute ma confiance dans leur avenir est
dans leur talent je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à mme anna marie agnès
labarre au titre du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et un sénateur du
parti de gauche
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
vous me permettrez de ne pas m'inscrire
dans votre enthousiasme et d'apporter
une autre tonalité à ce projet de loi
comme vous le savez je suis déjà
intervenu dans cet hémicycle pour
m'opposer à l'adoption de cette loi par
le sénat
force est de constater que malgré
quelques modifications à la marge
le texte qui est ressorti de l'assemblée
nationale participe de la même
conception libérale de votre vision de
l'agriculture conception identique à
celle de la commission européenne
contrairement à ce que vous voulez nous
faire croire à ce titre je voulais
évoquer les négociations autour de
l'accord économique et commercial global
entre l'union européenne et le canada
accord négocié dans le dos des citoyens
européens
alors qu'il aura des conséquences
importantes sur leur quotidien et
notamment sur l'agriculture il pourrait
éliminer le droit des agriculteurs
d'emmagasiner de réutiliser et de vente
des semences
il pourrait donner aux société
biotechnologique pharmaceutique de
pesticides de semences et de céréales de
puissants nouveaux outils leur
permettant de décider comment se fera
l'agriculture et par qui voilà la vision
libérale de l'agriculture comme tout
d'autres secteurs de la société selon
l'union européenne vision que vous
semblez partager au terme de l'examen à
la vitesse grand v puisque en aller
simple de ce projet de loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture et de la
pêche
la déception du monde agricole peut être
grande en acceptant aucun amendement
fondamental à même de modifier la porte
est certes limitée de ce texte la
majorité présidentielle a choisi de
verrouiller le débat sur les questions
de fond rien sur les prix d'achat et les
revenus des agriculteurs
rien sur la gestion de l'offre et de la
régulation des marchés
rien sur le modèle agricole que la
france affirmait porter au niveau
communautaire et dans le cadre de
négociations internationales
pour nous la loi de modernisation de
l'agriculture ont redit aurait dû être
l'occasion de réorienter rapidement et
massivement l'agriculture vers des
systèmes de production écologiquement
responsable et permettant aux paysans de
vivre des saints
mais ses objectifs ne semble pas être
partagé par vous même pire le projet de
loi propose une véritable
restructuration globale de l'agriculture
française au nom de l'entreprise et de
la compétitivité ainsi l'élimination des
petits paysans devaient être encore
accéléré enfin il existe encore de
nombreux outils dans cette loi qui ne
soit qu' swan ne règleront rien aux
problèmes des agriculteurs ce quoi les
aggraveront monsieur le maire glorifie à
cet effet la contractualisation qui
selon lui lui permettra d'assurer une
rémunération à tous les agriculteurs au
moment où la production agricole a
besoin de régulation de maîtrise des
volumes produits
la contractualisation ne nous apparaît
pas comme une solution aux crises
agricoles actuelles la
contractualisation ne peut remplacer une
politique agricole latium des contrats
ne peut aboutir à la maîtrise des
volumes et des prix et nous allons vous
le démontrer monsieur le ministre a
affirmé dans cette assemblée je cite
nous assumons l'idée que la production
alimentaire et décider en fonction des
consommateurs dans cette optique
dans cette optique nous abandonnons les
quotas ainsi en pleine crise financière
qui démonte l'inanité des dix tours des
discours des libéraux
voilà la solution que propose le
gouvernement aux agriculteurs qui
n'arrivent plus à vivre de leur travail
le marché toujours le marché rien que le
marché si la généralisation des contrats
constitue en soi une bonne chose
elle ne peut en aucun cas garantir des
prix rémunérateur aux producteurs
qu'est ce qu'un contrat si ce n'est la
simple transcription d'un rapport de
force
pas grand chose de plus or le rapport de
force entre les producteurs et
industriels n'est pas bien entendu l
avantage des premiers qui obligera la
grande distribution accepte et des prix
rémunérateurs pour les agriculteurs
personne et encore moins dans un
contexte de marché structurellement
excédentaire du fait justement du
démantèlement des politiques publiques
de gestion des marchés de maîtrise des
productions en effet la volatilité des
prix qui fragilise le monde paysan est
une des conséquences de la suppression
des outils de régulation des productions
agricoles au niveau communautaire et
national
c'est sur ce cas n'est d'ailleurs
monsieur ministre à demi mots quand ils
prêts
si et je le cite toujours la
contractualisation c'est indispensable
c'est la seule réponse à vos la
volatilité des prix est une des
conséquences de la suppression des
quotas laitiers
la misère sociale dans laquelle est
plongé une grande partie de
l'agriculture est bien une des
conséquences des politiques des
régulations de la commission européenne
que nous propose alors le gouvernement
simplement d'accompagner seul ce
démantèlement en effet loin d'une date
de s'attaquer au problème des paysans la
contractualisation si elle ne se fait
pas sur un volume réguler va les
aggraver en cela la situation de la
production porcine est éclairante
alors que les échanges au sein de cette
filière sont contractualisés à près de
93%
les revenus des paysans se sont
dégradées du fait de l'absence d'une
régulation des volumes de production
ceci est la conséquence de la situation
d'excédent structurel que connaît la
filière depuis dix ans avec un taux
d'autosuffisance de 105 à 100 7 % ainsi
la contractualisation en cas de
surproduction entretenue par les
industriels ne constitue en rien une
véritable et ambitieuse politique
agricole
dès lors la contractualisation
généralisée par cette loi ne va pas
renforcer le pouvoir des producteurs et
ne va pas garantir une meilleure
répartition de la valeur ajoutée en leur
faveur a conclu un contrat individuel
entre producteurs et industriels ne
serait utile que s'il y a une maîtrise
publique de la production et négoce et
une glaciation collectif des prix sur la
base des coûts de production y compris
du travail or le gouvernement soutenu en
cela par la commission européenne ne
souhaite pas aller dans ce sens au nom
de la concurrence libre et non faussée
ce sont donc les marchés qui font la
pluie et le beau temps nous l'avons déjà
vu lors de l'adoption du soi disant plan
anti crise au niveau communautaire où le
seul indicateur pris en compte par les
libéraux étaient le cours de la bourse
un plan censé s'attaquer à la
spéculation acclamé par les marchés
quelle triste ironie pour l'agriculture
il s'agit de la même chose si la
contractualisation permettaient de
rééquilibrer le rapport de force entre
les producteurs et les acheteurs assuré
au premier des prix rémunérateurs
on peut imaginer que les industriels se
serait insurgé contre la loi jamais nous
ne les avons entendu se plaindre
trop content qu'ils étaient de voir la
passivité du gouvernement
en effet les industriels auront tendance
à ne pas contractualiser tous les
volumes pour se laisser un minimum de
souplesse et ce sont alors les paysans
n'ont comme non contractualisés qui
joueront le rôle de variable
d'ajustement
on n'aboutira donc à une inévitable
baisse des prix payés aux paysans
seule la loi porteuse de l'intérêt
général pourrait garantir un droit en
revenus pour les paysans en interdisant
la vente à perte par exemple et en
fixant des prix minimums rémunérateurs
et a pris contractualiser n'est pas un
prix rémunérateur
un autre qui est également mis en avant
dans cette loi le système assurantiel de
l'article 9
tout d'abord faut-il le rappeler un
système assurantiel ne crée pas de
richesse mais réparti la richesse
existante
jamais donc il ne peut remplacer une
politique publique et remédier à
l'instabilité des prix agricoles
mais surtout le système aujourd'hui
proposés se résume ainsi beaucoup
d'argent public au profit des compagnies
d'assurance pour le bénéfice d'une
minorité d'agriculteurs nous sommes dans
la même logique d'élimination il y aura
ceux qui pourront se payer de bonnes
couvertures et ceux qui ne pourront pas
et qui en cas de problèmes devront
arrêter leur activité contre ces
systèmes notre groupe proposait un
système mutualisé de garantie contre les
allées les aléas mais cela a été rejeté
par votre majorité
de plus face à la conversion de terres
agricoles en terres urbanisables de 50 à
70 milles hectares par an face à la
spéculation aux difficultés
d'installation à la concentration
foncière
las en l'absence de véritable volonté
politique d'inverser la tendance est
patente
malgré la création d'observatoires
départementaux de la consommation des
espaces agricoles
aucun objectif chiffré n'est fixé et
pratiquement aucun dispositif nouveau
n'est prévu il est bien envisagée la
création d'une taxe sur les plus values
réalisées sur la vente de terrains
agricoles devenus constructibles mais le
niveau de la taxe est totalement
insuffisant pour lutter contre la
spéculation foncière près des villes le
taux marginal de taxation de la plus
value est de 10% dans le meilleur des
cas
alors que le prix des terrains peut être
multipliée par plus de 100 suite à leur
classement en zone constructible
l'amendement du groupe crc spg qu'il
faut poser des levées ce taux à 50 % a
été rejeté par la majorité et vous
emporterez les conséquences voilà j'ai
relevé quelques outils mis en place par
cette loi qui ne permet permettent pas
de répondre aux enjeux agricoles voire
même les aggravent mais le projet de loi
brille aussi par ses membres
ainsi alors que la majorité des paysans
qui se tuent à la tâche qui ne gagnent
pas suffisamment pour vivre décemment
ce projet de loi intègre aucunement de
volet social
pourtant parce que les agriculteurs qui
sont de plus en plus précarisés se
suicident plus que les autres profonde
profession le taux du suicide des
agriculteurs exploitant le plus élevé
des catégories socio professionnelles à
32 pour cent mille contre 28 pour cent
mille chez les ouvriers et 8 pour cent
mille chez les professions
intellectuelles supérieures et que nous
propose le gouvernement rien j'ai déjà
dit que le législateur aurait été
inspiré d'instituer la règle des prix
rémunérateurs
afin de garantir à tous les agriculteurs
un droit au revenu mais la loi aurait dû
être le moment de s'attaquer au problème
de l'accès au métier au statut
d'exploitant l'accès au métier de paysan
est conditionnée à l'accès au statut
social du chef d'exploitation
celui ci confère une reconnaissance de
l'activité agricole de la personne et
donne donc accès aux droits spécifiques
des paysans le problème c'est que
l'accès au statut est conditionnée à
direction d'une ferme dont l'importance
va être au minimum d'une demi s est mit
surface minimum d'installation et cette
référence pose de nouveau de nombreux
problèmes
notre groupe les a déjà évoqué sans
aucune réponse valable de votre part
enfin il est consternant de voir que
cette loi ne mentionne nullement
l'inscription du modèle agricole
français au sein d'un environnement
international et particulièrement
européens surtout vue de l'échéance de
2013 pour la pac de crise aujourd'hui
démultiplie leurs effets premièrement la
crise écologique qui listent disqualifie
notre modèle de développement économique
basé sur le poids du petit wismes et
deuxièmement la crise économique causée
par le néolibéralisme mondialisé qui a
partout des réguler les échanges
l'agriculture se trouve au confluent de
ces deux crises
il devient urgent d'y répondre le modèle
productiviste d'agriculture intensive
doit laisser la place à une agriculture
soucieuse de son environnement avec des
productions relocaliser de même les
crises successives que l'agriculture a
connu ces dernières années
nous en avons eu encore l'exemple avec
la crise du lait montre les politiques
de dérégulation initiée par l'om c est
soutenu par l'union européenne doivent
prendre fin
la france doit promouvoir au niveau
communautaire la mise en oeuvre de
toutes les mesures permettant de
garantir des prix rémunérateur aux
producteurs par la mise en place d'un
prix minimum indicatif européen pour
chaque production par l'activation de
dispositions visant à appliquer le
principe de préférence communautaire par
la politique douanière européenne
garantissant que les produits importés
soient fabriqués dans des conditions
sociales et environnementales acceptable
et soit payer un juste prix aux
producteurs
de même la france doit promouvoir au
niveau communautaire
la mise en oeuvre de mécanismes de
régulation notamment le maintien ou la
création de quotas pour certaines
productions et l'activation en cas de
crise exceptionnelle d'outils de
stockage public de production agricole
et alimentaire
enfin nous devons mettre en place les
outils permettant une véritable
planification de la transition
écologique de l'agriculture
nous devons tendre vers une agriculture
beaucoup plus diversifiée réintégrant
activités agricoles élevage rapprochant
les cycles du carbone et de l'azoté une
agriculture relocaliser autonome
valorisant la richesse potentielle des
écosystèmes cultivées en lieu et place
des systèmes basés sur l' usage intensif
d'engrais chimiques de pesticides et sur
la motorisation à outrance une
agriculture qui nous permettra donc de
contribuer à la lutte contre le
changement climatique de diminuer
l'utilisation de carbone fossile et des
autres ressources non renouvelables de
produire des aliments de meilleure
qualité de protéger l'environnement des
contes animations diverses et de
restaurer la biodiversité
mais ceci implique une agriculture plus
intensive en travail est donc à la fois
des prix rémunérateurs pour payer le
travail agricole à son juste prix et une
véritable politique foncière
volontariste permettant de stopper la
course à l'agrandissement des
exploitations voire dans certaines
régions d'inverser ce phénomène en
facilitant l'installation d'agriculteurs
une loi qui ne prendraient pas en compte
l'ensemble des aspects que je viens
d'évoquer ne résoudrait pas les enjeux
auxquels l'agriculture de xxième siècle
doit répondre
loin de moderniser la situation cette
loi ne fait que retarder la date où il
nous faudra prendre des décisions
drastiques pour réparer les dégâts
sociaux et environnementaux du
libéralisme celle du modèle
d'agriculture productiviste qui lui est
lié dans ces conditions les sénateurs du
groupe crc spg votre votre roue contre
un texte de renoncement de ce
gouvernement a une autre ambition
agricole que celles que nous promet
l'union européenne nous voterons contre
un texte muel sur les questions
fondamentales des prix et des revenus de
l'installation les pratiques agricoles
de la recherche est en recul sur les
questions environnementales
nous ferons contrainte est ce inquiétant
au regard de l'état actuel de
l'agriculture européenne et nationale
contre un texte qui tourne le dos aux
enjeux alimentaires si l'achat collègues
la parole est un monsieur jean boyer
pour l'union centriste
madame la présidente chez ministre les
rapporteurs président la commission
affaires économiques et je dirai
simplement avocats de notre agriculture
chaque année on nous prononçons
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez sur les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire relative au projet de loi
demande de modernisation pardon agricole
le texte présenté par le gouvernement
tend à répondre à l'urgence de la crise
que traverse l'agriculture française
et puis l'après guerre monsieur le
ministre vous était jeune moi je suis un
ancien agriculteur l'agriculture travers
des péripéties successives elle a connu
des mutations des inquiétudes fondée en
1955 chers collègues il y avait 2
millions 300 mille exploitations en
france aujourd'hui il en reste 580 1000
ont dénombré 8 millions 500 mille actifs
alors qu'aujourd'hui ils sont un million
trois cent mille le poids de
l'agriculture dans le pib était cher
collègue 12% aujourd'hui les 2%
par contre il faut être objectif dans
les informations la part des subventions
dans le rbe est revenu brut
d'exploitation était de 2%
ce président fourcade aujourd'hui comme
vous le savez il est de 80% à cette
époque la mission principale de
l'agriculture était de nourrir les
hommes
aujourd'hui son rôle s'est ouvert il
s'est diversifié nous référer une
situation immédiate
c'est dire par exemple monsieur le
ministre mais vous se le dire est dans
ma conclusion que vous êtes un homme
un ministre qui tient le langage de
vérité le volume des exportations a
diminué de 20% entre 2008 et 2009 est
également que le revenu des agriculteurs
particulièrement de certaines filiales
comme par exemple la filiale laitière a
baissé de près de 50%
bref l'agriculture française est venue
morose elle est inquiète parce quand on
regarde dans luan quand on ne voit pas
je dirais d'arc en ciel à l'horizon dans
ton texte européen et mondial de cette
jungle économique social et parfois
démagogiques
il y à le vouloir mais y associent mais
il ya aussi le manque de vérité entre
l'association prix et qualité
ce texte ne répond pas tout à fait aux
défis que le monde agricole français
doit relever même chez le ministre
peut-il le faire
non parce que aussi la politique
agricole n'est pas une politique
franco-française
elle est au contraire une des rares
politiques les décisions
le cadre et les subventions se décide au
niveau européen or le texte intervient à
un moment où justement le bilan santé de
la pac
on vient prendre fin et les contours de
la pac 2013 ne sont pas encore dessiné
et de fortes incohérent subsistent en ce
ministre est facile à dire est difficile
à faire
ne fallait-il pas dans cette période
transitoire innover mais comme je pense
pas être un critiqueurs nature je ne
dirai rien là-dessus parce qu'elles
puissent difficile de construire que
deux critiques
la crise agricole était l'occasion
peut-être de soulever le paradoxe le
parador que l'on entend dans le commune
dans nos pays
selon lequel il est absurde de vouloir
conjuguer la défense du pouvoir d'achat
et donc la pression à la baisse des prix
la consommation avec la garantie d'un
revenu décent pour les producteurs de
base c'est-à-dire les agriculteurs la
loi répond un ensemble de mesures
diverses dont beaucoup témoignent d'une
nouvelle administration sud ministre je
dis ça sans aucune démagogie peut-être
d'une sur administration de notre
culture ou les complexités
administratives sont messieurs dames
décourageante
je dirais sans polémiques parfois
contradictoires toutefois dans cette loi
et les mains plusieurs fois nous sommes
importants
je dirais déterminant allez j'en ai voté
les circuits courts
très sincèrement nous pensons que cette
compétition que cette conception pardon
devrait être positive étant basées sur
le bon sens la transparence la sécurité
alimentaire mais aussi sur la
valorisation locale
il faudra monsieur ministre avec toute
légalité l'égalité souhaité on ne veut
pas faire d'infraction
l'accès au marché des producteurs locaux
puissent se réaliser afin de donner
satisfaction à tout le monde
en france c'est un peu le sentiment
monsieur ministre de la france d'en bas
peut-être elle a tort de penser ce
langage on veut souvent on laver plus
blanc que blanc dans l'alimentation il
faut certes avoir une rigidité mais il
ne faut pas qu'elle soit une disparité à
la fois sanitaire et réglementaires
un produit cher collègue qui a parcouru
plus de 2000 kilomètres avant d'arriver
dans l'assiette du consommateur peut-il
avoir c'est une interrogation madame la
collaboratrice du ministre peut-il avoir
les meilleures garanties qu'un produit
transparent qui est constituée qu'il
fabriquait à quelques dizaines
kilomètres
autre point positif du seul ministre
l'observatoire laiteries dans le débat
j'étais intervenu pour dire que c'était
une volonté très noble mais qui c'était
très difficile à pouvoir trouver une
transparence par exemple il tient le
ministre entre un cochon import pas je
veux pas faire les jeux de mots fabriqué
en haute loire qui se trouve à 12 cents
kilomètres de bretagne import fabriquées
en bretagne où la lima arrive à brest ou
ailleurs et tant mieux pour eux où il
n'y a pas de surcoût de bâtiments
d'élevage transport d'aliments donc est
meilleur marché où le ou les abattoirs
sont compétitifs et celui qui est
fabriquée entre guillemets dans un
département où il ya seulement 3500
tonnes de volume d'abattage dans ce
département de la france rurale ce
ministre fonctionnaires par respect on
mais je connais votre forte personnalité
qui est basée sur une sérénité reconnu
nationalement
alors autre point positif donc c'est
l'observatoire des prix alors daniel
dubois qui n'est pas là ce soir mais
qu'est un collègue bien connu on groupe
de l'union centriste et particuliers du
nouveau centre a rappelé l'utilité de
cet observatoire
ce qu'il se mesurera sa capacité de
rendre utile de rendre publique la liste
des transformateurs et des distributeurs
qui ne jouent pas le jeu de la
transparence des prix et des marges
espérons monsieur mise que l'efficacité
de son action ne sera pas écornée par le
fort encadrement de certaines procédures
en dehors de il faut que je regarde mon
temps en pendant encore de sa capacité
de sanctions l'utilité de cet
observatoire dépendra de la portée
auprès des politiques des professionnels
du public et des analyses et des
recommandations
c'est ainsi monsieur le ministre il aura
sa raison d'être
jean vient désormais à la quatrième
mesure et monsieur mise depuis des mois
avec une sérénité qui vous personne avis
vous entendez ce message et vous l'avez
partagé parce que vous avez la volonté
de l'appliquer juin désormais à la
quatrième mesure que l'on peut souligner
dans ce test
dans ce texte parce qu'elle est une
réponse pratique à distorsions de
compétitivité de compétitivité il s'agit
de l'assouplissement des seuils
déclenché les procédures d'autorisation
des bâtiments d'élevage
le groupe a proposé en vain une telle
mesure tout en la subordonnant à la mise
en place d'un méthaniseur collectif afin
de limiter l'augmentation des effluents
du gouvernement obtienne mines vous
savez plus que moi j'ai seulement appris
à semaine dernière n'a finalement
accepté cette mesure qu'à l'assemblée
nationale et nous nous en réjouissons
alors que l'abattage des porcs français
avaient stagné pendant de nombreuses
années l'allemagne connaissait une
croissance de 35% en dix ans espérons
que cette mesure permet de rattraper
notre compétitivité d'un secteur à bord
d'un ancien ministre
le volet contractualisation celle d'hier
qu'elle constituera je le pense
un point fort même si les durées de
contrat ne répondent pas à une
efficacité pérenne enfin sur le secteur
de la pêche c'est pas ma spécialité
parce qu adrien gouteyron le dirait en
haute loire les rivières sont tellement
petit qu'il n'ya même plus de saumon
alors dans secteur de la pêche il faut
que je sois fidèle à championne mais
ressent qui a longtemps défendu ce
dossier type
il permet ce projet de loi de mieux
appréhender de partager le diagnostic au
niveau de la ressource pour rendre plus
acceptable
les décisions de restriction de
restriction de la pêche mais de nombreux
sujets comme les outils financiers
fiscaux favorise le renouvellement des
flottes de pêche
elle devrait faire l'objet d'une
attention accrue du gouvernement car le
développement de l'agriculture et de la
pêche dépend de ses innovations et ses
investissements finalement quand nous
l'avions souhaité en première lecture
cette loi manque mais c'est pas facile
un peu d'ambition mais la porte monsieur
le ministre
des avancées que nous souhaitons
encourager l'union centriste votre à
tous les membres
ce texte parce qu'il faut pas seulement
être responsable d espérer mais il faut
être responsable et actif pour l'heure
le sort l'agriculture française de sa
compétitivité de sa régulation est entre
les mains de la commission européenne
permettez moi monsieur le ministre en
terminant de m'interroger sur
l'efficacité de notre politique
européenne en faveur de l'agriculture
française nos agricultures dans ce
contexte des 27
n'at-elle pas mangé depuis quelques
années son pain blanc
mais lors la fin le droit comme je viens
de le fier d'être responsable désespéré
alors travaillons mais smith ma question
puisqu'il en faut une pour qu'on puisse
y répondre
en france il y a plusieurs agriculture
il y à aussi l'agriculture de montagne
et dans cet hémicycle à jean paul
amoudry keane actuellement m'écoute pas
il ya jacques blanc qui n'est pas là
mais qui est un défenseur de
l'agriculteur je n'ai pas vu mais il
n'écoute pas il ya bien sûr adrien
gouteyron et il y a messieurs le
ministre dans les tribunes jean digonnet
qui est trésorier de l'anem qui sont là
pour cautionner que l'agriculture de
montagne
ne demande pas des privilèges mais d'une
manche mais demande une parité
alors monsieur le ministre je termine je
termine mesdames messieurs et que le bar
acteurs éminents les aviculteurs
apprécié monsieur le ministre
et je le dis sans démagogie savez
j'étais dit ça je suis gêné de le dire
j'étais sous lieutenant à l'armée et on
avait noté franchise parfois cros
cinglante
alors aujourd'hui avec la soit franchie
s'est atténuée mais elles restent vrais
alors les agriculteurs apprécie beaucoup
votre langage de vérité
il apprécie beaucoup votre le vote
regard objectif je dirais dans certains
domaines votre regard social dans une
profession qui est ébranlée mais qui je
crois je peux le dire n'a pas perdu
l'essentiel sont idéales son envie
d'entreprendre son amour de profession
pour cela elle doit garder quelque chose
de très fort c'est l'espérance
merci monsieur le ministre de nous aider
à la garder